افاد مدير مصر السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي
عبد الرحمن العربي ان الغارات الاسرائيليه
في حماه وطرطوس استهدفت مستودعات سلاح لا
تتبع الجيش السوري ودمرت بطاريات للدفاع
الجوي
الصيام لان مستودعات للايرانيين واقعه في
جبال مصياف بطرطوس لانها ضمن البنك اهداف
اسرائيل على ما يبدو داخل التراب السوري
اقله في اغار الصباح اليوم جرى تدمير
مستودع للايرانيين يقع في منطقه جبليه
متداخله بين محافظه طي حماه وطرطوس اي
منطقه غرب مصياف ادت لتدمير هذا المستودع
في التفاح الذي شاهدناه في تدمير هذا
المستودع كان هناك صواريخ اخرى استهدفت
بعض بطاريات الدفاع الجوي هناك خمسه اثنان
منهم قتلوا اثنان كانوا من يعني في منطقه
المستودع وح
راس وثلاثه جرحى من القوات النظام في
القصف الاسرائيلي
وكانت الانباء السوريه سانا كانت افادت ان
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه شنت هجوما
جديدا بالصواريخ استهدف بعض المواقع في
منطقه مصياف في حماه ونقلت الوكاله عن
مصدر عسكري قوله ان قصف اسرائيليا استهدف
بعض النقاط في دفاع محافظه تيطرطوس وحماه
مع ادى الى اصابه ثلاثه عسكريين بجروح
ووقوع بعض الخسائر الماديه واكد المقصد ان
وسائل الدفاع الجوي تصدت لهذه الصواريخ
واسقطت بعضها ايضا
[موسيقى]
ويعود الينا من مدينه كومنت البريطانيه
مدير المرصد السوري حقوق الانسان رامي عبد
الرحمن من جديد وهل ما زالت توتر سيد
الموقف في حماه وطرطوس بعد هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه ام ان الامور عندي طبيعتها
الان
العالم يبدو بانها عادت صباح الخير مجددا
عادت الى طبيعتها الان الاستهداف مثل ما
ذكرنا هو لتدمير مستودع حقيقه الامر يقع
في ريف مصياف الغربي المتداخل مع محافظه
طرطوس وايضا هناك كان استهدافات لبطاريات
الدفاع الجوي في محافظه طرطوس
القتيلين هم في المستودع من حراس المستودع
يعني اصبحوا اشلاء او لم يعد لديه لهم اجل
ايضا بالاضافه للجرحى من عناصر قوات
النظام بينهم الضابط على الاقل في اصيبوا
باستهداف بطاريه بطاريه للدفاع الجوي كما
تحاول التصدي للاستهداف الاسرائيلي على
الاراضي السوريه الحصيله حتى اللحظه مثل
ما ذكرنا بينهم ثلاثه جرحى من السوريين
اثنان اشلائهم حقيقه الامر ان وجدت في
مصياف في غرب مصياف في تدمير المستودع
وهذا المستودع او منطقه المستودع كان فيها
مستودع سابقا دمر بشكل كامل في الخامس
والعشرين من شهر اغسطس الفائت وكان فيه
الصواريخ الايرانيه او التي جرى تصنيعها
وتجميعها في منطقه البحوث العلميه في
مصياف وجمع تخزينها في هذه الجبال السوريه